JUAN WILLIAMS, JESSE WATTERS,
KATIE PAVLICH AND GREG GUTFELD.
IT’S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE" ."
WE ARE WAITING ON THE
PRESIDENT’S FAKE NEWS AWARDS AND
HAS RELATIONS WITH THE PRESS ARE
MORE CONTENTIOUS THAN EVER.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, DID YOU SAY
YOU WANT MORE PEOPLE TO COME IN
FROM NORWAY?
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> IS THAT TRUE, MR. PRESIDENT?
>> I WANT THEM TO COME IN FROM
EVERYWHERE, EVERYWHERE.
THANK YOU, EVERY ONE.
>> JUST CAUCASIAN OR WHITE
COUNTRIES OR OTHER PARTS OF THE
WORLD WHERE THERE ARE PEOPLE OF
COLOR?
>> Kimberly: WE ARE NOT SURE
WHAT TO EXPECT BUT SOMETHING IS
PLANNED AND WE ARE GOING TO GIVE
AN EYE ON.
SOME MEMBERS OF THE PRESIDENT’S
OWN PARTY ARE TAKING HIM TO TASK
FOR ATTACKS ON THE PRESS.
JOHN McCAIN WROTE AN OP    OP-ED
JEFF FLAKE OFFER THIS.
>> THE ENEMY OF THE PEOPLE WAS
HOW THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES CALLED THE FREE
PRESS IN 2017.
MR. PRESIDENT  , IT IS A TESTAMT
TO THE CONDITION OF OUR
DEMOCRACY THAT OUR OWN PRESIDENT
USES WORDS INFAMOUSLY SPOKEN BY
JOSEPH STALIN TO DESCRIBE HIS
ENEMIES.
WHEN A FIGURE IN POWER
REFLECTIVELY CALLS ANY PRESS
THAT DOESN’T SUIT HIM "FAKE
NEWS," IT IS THAT A PERSON WHO
SHOULD BE THAT FIGURE OF
SUSPICION, NOT THE PRESS.
2018 MUST BE THE YEAR IN WHICH
THE TRUTH TAKES A STAND AGAINST
POWER THAT WOULD WEAKEN IT.
LET US RESOLVE TO BE ALLIES OF
THE TRUTH AND NOT PARTNERS AND
ITS DESTRUCTION.
>> Kimberly: THE WHITE HOUSE
HAD THIS TO SAY ABOUT THE
SENATOR’S SPEECH.
>> I FOUND IT QUITE INTERESTING
THAT HE IS COMING OUT TO ATTACK
THIS PRESIDENT CONSIDERING HE IS
ONE THAT WAS RECENTLY DEFENDING
AND ACTUALLY OPPRESSIVE REGIME.
HE WENT TO CUBA A FEW WEEKS AGO
AND SERVED AS A MOUTHPIECE FOR
THE OPPRESSIVE CUBAN GOVERNMENT.
HE’S NOT CRITICIZING THE
PRESIDENT BECAUSE HE’S AGAINST
OPPRESSION.
HE’S CRITICIZING THE PRESIDENT
BECAUSE HE HAS TERRIBLE POLL
NUMBERS.
I THINK HE IS LOOKING FOR SOME
ATTENTION.
>> Kimberly: LOOKING FOR SOME
ATTENTION, GREG.
CAN YOU RELATE?
>> Greg: I CAN.
THE ULTIMATE JOKE BY
DONALD TRUMP COULD BE THE FAKE
NEWS AWARDS IS FAKE NEWS.
AND IT NEVER HAPPENS.
JUST AS A NICE PRACTICAL JOKE.
HERE’S THE PROBLEM WITH FLAKE, I
CALL THAT FLAKE NEWS.
HE IS COMPARING A TYRANT,
STALIN, TO THE PRESIDENT OF A
REPUBLIC.
IT’S A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT.
IT IS DISHONEST.
IT’S HYPERBOLE.
YOU CAN CRITICIZE THE PRESS IN
AMERICA.
IN FACT, FLAKE KIND OF WORRIED
ME WHEN HE SAID THE ONLY
OBJECTIVE TRUTH WAS IN THE MEDIA
WHICH IS JUST NUTS.
IF THE MEDIA WOULD ADMIT IT’S
BIASED, THEN ACCUSATIONS OF
FALSE NEWS WOULD FADE.
IT IS THE BIGGEST LIE OF ALL.
DENYING THAT REPORTERS ARE NOT
CLOUDED BY THEIR OWN
CONFIRMATION BIAS.
WE KNOW IT.
IT HAPPENS HERE.
IT HAPPENS THERE.
YOU HAVE NO RIGHT TO CRITICIZE
ANYBODY FOR CRITICIZING THE
MEDIA BECAUSE IT’S NOT ABOUT
LIES.
IT’S ABOUT SHAPING YOUR STORY
BASED ON BIAS.
THE OTHER FLAW IN FLAKE’S
REASONING, AND THIS IS DONE FOR
ATTENTION.
FLAKE NEWS.
IT’S THAT TRUMP IS BAD FOR THE
PRESS.
NO ONE HAS EVER BEEN BETTER FOR
THE PRESS IN HISTORY.
YESTERDAY’S MEDICAL PRESS
CONFERENCE, HE WOULDN’T LET THE
DOCTOR GO BACK INSIDE UNTIL HE
ANSWERED EVERY QUESTION.
FOR EIGHT YEARS THEY WERE IN A
COMA UNDER OBAMA BECAUSE THEY
AGREED WITH EVERYTHING OBAMA
DID.
BECAUSE THEY CAN’T STAND TRUMP
TRUMP, -- TRUMP GAVE THEM A
LIVER TRANSPLANT.
THEY ARE NOW LIVE AND THEY ARE
BAD?
NO, THEY SHOULD BE BOWING BEFORE
TRUMP FOR ACTUALLY BRINGING THEM
BACK TO LIFE.
HE REALLY IS LIKE AN ORGAN
TRANSPLANT FOR THE PRESS.
>> Kimberly: SO TRUE.
KATIE, WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF IT?
>> Katie: I WOULD SAY THE
WHITE HOUSE PRESS CORPS HAS EVER
BEEN SO INTERESTING.
THE BRIEFINGS EVERY DAY AND THE
REPORTERS WHO SIT IN THAT ROOM
WILL NEVER USE TO GET ANY TV
ATTENTION ARE GETTING ATTENTION.
BACK TO JEFF FLAKE’S FLOOR
SPEECH.
IF HE IS SO CONCERNED ABOUT
PROTECTING THE FIRST AMENDMENT,
PROTECTING THE PRESS, WISELY
BOWING OUT EARLY INSTEAD OF
STAYING AND FIGHTING, KEEPING
HIS SEAT IN ARIZONA.
INSTEAD HE IS ROLLING OVER
GOING -- DOING THIS ON HIS LAST
STAND.
WHAT HE SAID WASN’T TRUE.
HE SAID THIS HAS NEVER HAPPENED
BEFORE, THIS KIND OF ATTACK IS
UNPRECEDENTED.
POLITICIANS, WHETHER YOU ARE THE
PRESIDENT OR CONGRESS, HAVE
ALWAYS HAD A PRECARIOUS
RELATIONSHIP.
THAT’S THE WHOLE POINT OF HAVING
A FREE, INDEPENDENT PRESS.
THE GOVERNMENT IS HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
THEY ARE ALWAYS GOING TO DEAL
WITH THIS.
WE ARE GOING TO SEE THIS FOR THE
NEXT THREE YEARS, DEFINITELY THE
NEXT SEVEN AT PRESIDENT TRUMP
GETS REELECTED.
THEY NEED EACH OTHER.
TRUMP LIKES THE ATTENTION,
WHETHER IT’S GOOD OR BAD, AND
THE PRESS CERTAINLY LIKES THE
ATTENTION, ESPECIALLY THOSE IN
THE WHITE HOUSE PRESS CORPS.
>> Jesse: TALK ABOUT ACOSTA
FOR A SECOND.
I RESPECT HIM BUT HE IS A TOTAL
DRAMA QUEEN.
IF ANOTHER CORRESPONDENT HAD
TREATED PRESIDENT OBAMA LIKE
THAT, HE WOULD’VE THROWN HIM IN
GITMO.
VERY DISRESPECTFUL.
FLAKE, A NOBLE STATESMAN, BUT
TOTALLY OUT OF CONTROL.
STALIN KILLED 20 MILLION PEOPLE.
TRUMP THE ONLY PEOPLE HE’S BEEN
KILLING HAS BEEN ISIS.
YOU CAN CRITICIZE THE PRESS.
IT DOESN’T MEAN YOU ARE
ATTACKING THE FIRST AMENDMENT.
FAKE NEWS IS THE ENEMY OF THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS THE ONLY
REPUBLICAN THAT’S ACTUALLY SAID
IT.
HE’S BEEN INCREDIBLY OPEN.
HE JUST DID A 40 MINUTE ON THE
RECORD INTERVIEW WITH
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" AT
MAR-A-LAGO.
ALSO DID ANOTHER ON THE RECORD
INTERVIEW WITH
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL," JUST
SPOKE TO REUTERS FOR 45 MINUTES.
HIS OWN DOCTOR TOLD US THINGS WE
DIDN’T REALLY WANT TO KNOW FOR
AN HOUR IN THE PRESS ROOM.
INCREDIBLY TRANSPARENT AND YOU
JUXTAPOSE THAT TO
PRESIDENT OBAMA WHO PUT MORE
WHISTLE-BLOWERS IN JAIL THAN
ANYBODY ELSE, PROSECUTED THEM,
HAD HILLARY CLINTON TYING UP
REPORTERS AND ROPES.
I REMEMBER THAT.
NEVER EVEN WENT ON FOX NEWS, WAS
TERRIFIED.
I DIDN’T HEAR A LOT OF PEOPLE
SAYING OH, YOU KNOW,
PRESIDENT OBAMA IS ENCOURAGING
OTHER LEADERS ACROSS THE GLOBE
TO CRACK DOWN.
WHEN PRESIDENT OBAMA WAS USING
THE IRS TO CRACK DOWN ON
POLITICAL OPPONENTS, I DIDN’T
HEAR JEFF FLAKE SAYING HE IS
INSPIRING WORLD LEADERS TO CRACK
DOWN ON THEIR POLITICAL
OPPONENTS.
IT’S BALONEY.
>> Juan: IT IS BALONEY
APPARENTLY BEING CUT BY
REPUBLICANS.
NOT ONLY JEFF FLAKE,
JOHN McCAIN TODAY ON THE OP-ED
PAGE OF "THE WASHINGTON POST"
SANG THE PRESIDENT’S RHETORIC,
THE WAY HE TALKS ABOUT THE
PRESS, THE ENEMY OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, AGAIN, PICKING UP ON
WHAT FLAKE SAID ABOUT THAT BEING
SOLOMON -- IT’S A BAD EXAMPLE IN
THE PHILIPPINES AND OTHER
COUNTRIES WHERE REPORTERS
FACE INTIMIDATION, HARASSMENT
AND THE TRUTH IS CONSTANTLY
BEING SUPPRESSED.
>> Jesse: NOW ALL OF A SUDDEN
HE IS LEADING OTHER LEADERS TO
CRACK DOWN ON THE PRESS?
>> Katie: DID THE CRACKDOWN
START WHEN TRUMP GOT ELECTED?
>> Jesse: I THINK VENEZUELA
HAS BEEN THROWING REPORTERS IN
JAIL.
>> Juan: THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA, A COUNTRY WITH A
FIRST AMENDMENT PROTECTION FOR
THE PRESS SHOULD NOT BE GIVING
ANY COMFORT OR SUPPORT TO
AUTOCRATS AROUND THE WORLD WHO
ARE SEEKING TO SUPPRESS THE
PRESS.
THAT’S WHAT THIS PRESIDENT IS
DOING.
>> Jesse: PRETTY IMPRESSIVE
GOING AFTER VENEZUELA, IRAN,
NORTH KOREA.
HE’S REALLY CRACKING DOWN ON
OPPRESSIVE REGIMES.
>> Juan: SLAMMING CNN.
REMEMBER THAT?
OH, I FORGOT ABOUT IT.
>> Jesse: THAT WAS A JOKE.
>> Kimberly: IT DIDN’T HAPPEN.
>> Juan: I THINK HE DELIGHTED
IN IT.
>> Greg: WHAT IS WRONG WITH
THAT?
WHAT IS WRONG WITH THE LIGHTING
IN A JOKE?
WE ARE IN A PERIOD WHERE YOU
DELIGHT IN A JOKE, YOU ARE
SOMEHOW SETTING A BAD EXAMPLE
FOR OTHER COUNTRIES.
>> Juan: HOW ABOUT THIS?
TRUMP SHOULD GET THE LIFETIME
ACHIEVEMENT AWARD FOR FAKE NEWS.
THE BIRTHER MOVEMENT, OBAMACARE
IS DEAD?
HOW ABOUT OBAMA WAS WIRETAPPING
TRUMP TOWER?
>> Jesse: ACTUALLY PROVE -- GO
>> Juan: NOT TRUE.
HOW ABOUT THIS?
THE BIGGEST INAUGURAL CROWD
EVER.
HOW ABOUT THIS ONE: LANDSLIDE.
I WON IN A LANDSLIDE.
HOW ABOUT --
ECONOMIC GROWTH COMING ANY
MINUTE, HE SAYS.
>> Greg: WE ARE GETTING PLUS
3% MAYBE THREE MONTHS IN A ROW
FOR THE FIRST TIME SINCE 2005.
I’M OKAY WITH THAT.
>> Juan: THIS GUIDE MAKES UP
MORE STUFF AND HE SHOULD BE
CROWNED THE FOUNTAINHEAD OF FAKE
NEWS.
>> Greg: MAYBE THAT’S WHAT HE
WILL DO.
THE FACT IS, WE KNOW WHAT TRUMP
IS.
HE DOESN’T ACTUALLY HIDE WHAT
TRUMP IS PURE HE IS MORE
SEE-THROUGH THAN THE GUY IN
OPERATION, THE LITTLE GUY WHEN
YOU CAN PULL OUT THE ORGANS.
YOU KNOW EVERYTHING.
AMERICA KIND OF ACCEPTS THAT.
IT’S THE MEDIA THAT DOESN’T
ACCEPT.
THE MEDIA DOESN’T ACCEPT A
FUNDAMENTAL TRUTH THAT WE ALL
KNOW, THAT THEY ARE CLOUDED BY
CONFIRMATION BIAS.
WE SEE IT EVERYWHERE.
I WILL ADMIT IT HAPPENS TO ME,
BUT THE MEDIA GETS UP IN ARMS
WHEN YOU POINT OUT THE OBVIOUS
FACT.
HE’S NOT SAYING THE
FIRST AMENDMENT SUCKS.
HE IS SAYING HE’S TIRED OF
STORIES BEING SHAPED BY
CONFIRMATION BIAS.
THAT’S ALL IT IS.
>> Juan: YOU KNOW WHAT, THERE
ARE WORKING JOURNALISTS WHO TRY
TO TELL YOU EXACTLY WHAT --
>> Katie: YOU KNOW WHAT MAKES
THEM LOOK BAD?
JIM ACOSTA.
>> Juan: HE LIES ABOUT HAVING
SAID S-HOLE.
>> Katie: YOU KNOW WHO MAKES
GOOD JOURNALISTS WERE DOING GOOD
WORK, PUTTING OUT THE FACTS.
PEOPLE LIKE JIM ACOSTA WHO GO
INTO THE OVAL OFFICE, ASK A
LEGITIMATE QUESTION ABOUT THE
KINDS OF PEOPLE PRESIDENT TRUMP
WANTS TO COME HERE.
HE ANSWERS THE QUESTION AND SAYS
EVERYBODY AND JIM ACOSTA FOLLOWS
UP WITH A LOADED, RACIAL
QUESTION ABOUT ONLY WHITE PEOPLE
BEING ABLE TO COME.
THAT’S THE PROBLEM.
>> Juan: THAT’S A PROBLEM WHEN
IN FACT PEOPLE WERE THINKING
BACK?
>> Greg: TRUMP ANSWERED THE
QUESTION.
>> Katie: HE ANSWERED A
FOLLOW-UP, LOADED QUESTION.
TRUMP TOLD HIM TO GET OUT, JUST
LIKE OBAMA WOULD TELL EVERYONE
TO GET OUT.
THEN HE FOLLOWS UP ON TWITTER
SAYING HE IS THE VICTIM, THAT HE
NEVER THOUGHT IT WOULD HAPPEN IN
AMERICA.
>> Greg: AS THOUGH THERE ARE
OTHER COUNTRIES THAT ARE BAD.
>> Juan: HERE IS THE POINT,
KATIE.
JIM ACOSTA, AS A CORRESPONDENT
IN THE OVAL OFFICE, SHOULD BE AN
ADVERSARIAL FORCE, QUESTIONING.
>> Katie: A LIBERAL
ADVERSARIAL FORCE?
OR A NONBIASED?
>> Jesse: ADVERSARIAL FORCES
WHEN PRESIDENT OBAMA WAS
PRESIDENT.
HE GOT QUESTIONS, WHAT’S THE
MOST ENCHANTING THING ABOUT
BEING PRESIDENT?
>> Juan: YOU ARE SAYING YOU
DON’T THINK PRESIDENT OBAMA, WHO
WAS EXCORIATED BY THIS NETWORK.
IT >> Katie: AND HE EXCORIATED
US ALL THE TIME.
>> Juan: I DON’T SEE YOU GOT
ANY EASY TREATMENT.
>> Kimberly: YOU CAN’T BLAME
US FOR OBAMACARE.
>> Katie: JUST TELLING IT LIKE
IT IS.
>> Greg: YOU HAVE TO WONDER,
PEOPLE WHO ESCAPE THE USSR WERE
HERE NOW AND WHO ARE OLD ENOUGH
TO REMEMBER HOW BAD IT WAS THERE
WHEN THEY HEAR SOMEBODY LIKE
FLAKE MAKE THAT COMPARISON.
I’VE RUN INTO RUSSIANS WHO LOOK
AT TRUMP AS A SYMBOL OF
CAPITALISM, SOMETHING THAT
ACTUALLY WORKS.
>> Jesse: YOU RUN INTO
RUSSIANS?